Michael avenatti and his client stormy
Daniels lost one of their defamation
suits against President Trump and will
now have to pay Trump's attorneys fees
let's talk about why
[Music]
hey legal eagles let's think like a
lawyer today we're gonna talk about
defamation law and one of my favorite
laws in California the anti slap statute
yes lawyers actually have favorite laws
today we're going to cover three things
first what in the world is an anti slap
number two why did AB not Ian Clifford's
aka stormy Daniels lose this particular
defamation lawsuit and number three how
much will a vanity and Clifford's have
to pay president Trump as always hit
that bell leave an objection if you
disagree with me in the comments and let
me know what legal topic I should cover
next and as usual
Stella the legal beagle is reading all
of your comments so please keep things
stella safe alright so on to the anti
slap statute anti slap statutes exist to
protect an act in furtherance of
someone's right to petition or free
speech in connection with a public issue
the bottom line is that legislators know
that some people will use litigation as
a sword instead of a shield because they
know that litigation is very very
expensive a lawsuit can be used to
censor certain people if used in the
wrong hands so for example if you didn't
like a yelp review or someone's opinion
you might sue them and even if you lost
that lawsuit you might be able to
inflict huge pain and force them to
remove their speech by forcing them to
incur huge legal fees so in response
many states pass what are called anti
slap statues slap stands for strategic
lawsuit against public participation so
anti slap you want to prevent people
from stifling speech by using strategic
lawsuits California has one of the
strongest for complicated reasons I
won't go into the court in this
particular case used the Texas statute
but most of the analysis remains the
same so an anti slap motion is presented
as a special motion to strike when you
file an anti slap motion it stops the
case they force the plaintiff to show
that the complaint
both legally sufficient and supported by
prima facie evidence usually the
plaintiff doesn't have that burden they
can simply file a lawsuit by showing
that their claim has legal merit not
that there is supporting evidence
necessarily that's what discovery is for
by the way links to all of these
documents including judge Otero's
decision in this case will be down in
the description below as well as a lot
of the relevant law but now here's where
it gets particularly interesting from my
perspective if you file an anti slap
motion and the court rules in your favor
it will both dismiss the plaintiffs case
but it will also award the defendant
attorneys fees and court costs the court
fees are mandatory and they are not
discretionary in the American system
usually regardless of who wins the case
both the plaintiff and the defendant
have to pay for their own fees but if
you lose an anti slap motion which means
the court says you file the strategic
lawsuit for the purposes of stifling
speech then you as the plaintiff have to
pay for the legal fees of the defendant
so that can be a great reason why as a
defendant you would want to file one of
these motions because you can get
attorneys fees from the plaintiff so
let's dig in to the facts of this case
now based on the procedural posture of
this case the court is assuming the
plaintiff's facts to be true now that's
only for this very discrete part of the
case it's testing to see if the facts as
given by the plaintiff state a legal
claim if the case went forward then
Clifford aka stormy Daniels would have
to prove her allegations with facts but
at the moment the court is taking these
allegations as true so according to her
complaint miss Clifford alleges that she
began an intimate relationship with mr.
Trump in 2006 five years later she
claims that in May of 2011 she agreed to
cooperate with In Touch magazine
to talk about her relationship with
Donald Trump she apparently agreed to
speak to the magazine after her
ex-boyfriend approached the magazine
without her approval
Clifford alleges that a few weeks after
she agreed to talk to in touch magazine
an unidentified man approached her and
threatened her in Las Vegas cliff
alleges that the man approached her
threatened her daughter and told her to
quote leave Trump alone and forget the
story then after mr. Trump was elected
president Clifford worked with a sketch
artist to provide a sketch of what she
remembered the undisclosed man looked
like and released that to the public the
day after mr. Trump tweeted out from his
Twitter account at at real Donald Trump
stating quote a sketch years later about
a non-existent man a total con job
playing the fake news media for fools
paren but they know it exclamation point
Trump posted this tweet in response to
another tweet which compared the sketch
that Miss Clifford released to a photo
of her ex-boyfriend side-by-side
according to Clifford's argument she
claims that Trump meant to convey that
she was a liar that she could not be
trusted and she was falsely complaining
about crimes that never happened on the
basis of Trump's tweet she contended
that it was false it constituted
defamation and that a constituted
defamation per se because it charged her
with committing a serious crime now all
of this is pending in federal court in
the Central District of California which
is located partially in Los Angeles and
this is before federal court Judge James
Otero judge Otero is a smart very
capable judge I actually X turned on the
Ninth Circuit which is the court
directly above the Central District of
California literally next door to judge
Otero's chambers so I used to know Judge
Otero's clerks very very well so let's
talk about judge Otero's analysis in
this particular case there's a two-part
analysis that the court must go over
first is to determine whether the
defamation suit that Miss Clifford's
filed is related to president Trump's
free speech and public participation
here the court had no problem
determining that it was in fact related
to Trump's free speech no surprise there
this is quintessential free speech
twitter is quickly becoming this
generations public square so it's no
surprise that the court found not only
free speech but public participation
almost anything that relates to the
president should probably be considered
public participation
for the purposes of an anti slap suit so
that takes us to the second question did
Clifford's establish a prima facie case
of defamation and the court said she did
not so the court agreed with president
Trump's argument that the tweet in
question constituted rhetorical
hyperbole and rhetorical hyperbole
normally associated with politics and
public discourse is one of those things
that cannot constitute defamation the
First Amendment often protects opinion
and rhetorical flourishes and
extravagant exaggeration used for
rhetorical effect and the court found
that president Trump's tweet was exactly
that kind of rhetorical language a
published statement that is pointed or
exaggerated or heavily laden with
emotional rhetoric or moral outrage
cannot generally constitute a defamatory
statement now the context particularly
matters in filings before the court and
in a public setting miss Clifford
challenged the legitimacy of President
Trump's victory in 2016 now you can
agree with those statements or not but
it's pretty clear that she presented
herself as an adversary to the president
and the court found I think correctly
that Trump's tweet served as a public
rejoinder a contradiction of the claims
that Clifford was making against the the
president to me and I think a lot of
First Amendment lawyers this seems like
the right outcome you might agree or
disagree with the president but it's
important to have a marketplace of ideas
and opinions and as judge Otero pointed
out in his decision quote if this Court
were to prevent mr. Trump from engaging
in this type of rhetorical hyperbole
against a political adversary it would
significantly hamper the Office of the
President any strongly-worded response
by a president to another politician or
public figure could constitute an action
for defamation this would deprive the
country of discourse common to the
political process I think that's right
the next political opinion to be
silenced could be your own the point of
the anti slap statute is to prevent
lawsuits from silencing the little guy
and while Trump obvious
doesn't fit the definition of the little
guy for many people legal fees can be
crushing so you may not like certain
political rhetoric but on balance were
better off with more speech and not less
and we certainly don't want to bankrupt
people for their political opinions so I
think that's why this was a relatively
easy decision for judge Otero this is a
pretty clear case of political rhetoric
and rhetorical hyperbole this is one of
those rare defamation wins for president
Trump who often threatens to file his
own defamation suits but seldom actually
does and although he usually rails
against defamation and libel laws in
this country he was actually able to use
those against the plaintiff in this
particular case now moments before I
started filming this President Trump
tweeted out quote federal judge throws
out stormy Daniels misspelled lawsuit
versus Trump Trump is entitled to full
legal fees end quote
at Fox News great now I can go after
horse face and her third-rate lawyer in
the great state of Texas
she will confirm the letter she signed
she knows nothing about me a total con
you know its statements like this that
make it really hard to defend political
speech but I still think the court got
it right in this particular case but I
should point out that Trump's tweet is
not correct this ruling has nothing to
do with the sister litigation over the
Michael Cohen non-disclosure agreement
or the other cases involving Michael
Cohen president Trump stormy Daniels and
Michael avenatti this was just the
discrete case of defamation over the
2018 tweet which implied that stormy
Daniels was a liar and a quote total con
job it also has nothing to do with how
much clifford's does or does not know
about the president or whether she
engaged in a sexual relationship which I
think at this point is a matter of
public knowledge so even in victory the
president gets a lot of the legal
aspects of this wrong that's not
surprising this is complicated stuff
okay so that takes us to point number
three how much is this going to cost
stormy Daniels here the fees are
mandatory and Trump's lawyers are
expensive the court will generally pay
for
reasonable attorneys fees but nine times
out of ten the court will generally just
look to the fees that the defendant
actually incurred and will order the
plaintiff to pay those but again this
ruling only applies to this specific
defamation case and not the three to six
other Cohen Trump Clifford matters that
are before judge Otero and are still
pending so even though this case was
stopped in the very early stages it
still required lots of different
attorneys on both sides lots of legal
briefing and a ton of argument thus
Trump's lawyers are likely to ask for
and get somewhere between 50 and
$100,000 from Stephanie Clifford
so do you agree please leave your
objections in the comments below and
until next time I'll see you in court